hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief I'm Erik Bosse joining me today
are Sam fashion hello that is my voice
Phillip Melina and this is mine and our
special guest Sam Levine of DC daily
hello thank you it's so nice to be here
thank you big fans
oh very sweet of you and I don't believe
[Music]
we got a big DC episode today we're
gonna be talking about Shazam and the
Joker trailer we're also going to cover
some news about the fate of dr. Erik
Selvig an Avengers end game oh my god
okay please double use okay and updates
on the new Terminator movie that's in
the works and Kumail Nanjiani
potentially joining the MCU in
Terminator T's a question it's just how
many times are there gonna be one also
we can have an update later about a
really exciting thing we're doing we
just crossed 2 million subscribers as
ngratulations thank you thank you guys
so much but part of our celebration is
gonna be a big live event that we're
gonna be doing where you guys will be
there with us it's Avengers related if
there's a very that's a very hot ticket
right now you a lot of you did not get
your tickets I'm just saying stay tuned
we might have you and we might maybe we
have a ticket for you or something here
in LA I'm really excited to talk about
it later in the show the reason to stick
around yeah and yeah it's a big deal
that we cross 2 million subscribers we
don't waiting on let's say a lot of you
have been great in the comments saying
oh you're so close to 2 million and no
other channel deserves it more than you
guys and thank you all for saying that
him thank you all for watching makes a
whole new rockstars team both everyone
on camera and off camera and Sam and mod
as well mod couldn't be here today and
to everyone behind the scenes the Itami
Becht all scream producer Devin Devin
all of our editors we're like the little
operation that could we could not be
more proud of what we do here but stick
around the end of this episode we'll
have a short what five-second dance
party so yeah that way but we cannot use
any copyrighted music and video will be
taken down immediately then why 5
seconds yeah and so we also have a
reminder right that this is a podcast
yeah yeah so the weekly reminder that we
are available in audio that's a good
reason to keep our dance
a short later you can find us on Apple
podcast the Himalaya app or anywhere you
get your podcast and also by the way our
Game of Thrones feed it's called
Westeros weekly that's not just the
Westeros weekly show that's gonna be the
actual breakdowns of Game of Thrones
that we're gonna be doing that's gonna
be our Game of Thrones Theory videos all
audio versions of that and here's the
like the crazy thing that we've never
done before the Game of Thrones
breakdowns everything we're doing you're
gonna get them earlier on that feed
because audio is real easy to put
together and videos real hard so again
if you want our thoughts on it and
analysis and Game of Thrones as early as
possible definitely check out that beat
it's called Westeros weekly also an
Apple podcast also an MLA app or a Reno
right here on YouTube so you don't miss
the visual chaos that's gonna occur when
we try and deliver your Twitter
questions by Raven for real we are
trying to make Raven to deliver your
questions and it's gonna be a mess
having Birds flat or heads is not as fun
if you're just listening to it you got
to see the panic in a row yeah and they
don't like being thrown oh they really
don't but they can play on their own
okay well let's get to today's main
topic Shazam Shazam open this weekend
and it's a newest entry to the DC EU
it's starting Zachary Levi it's directed
by David F Sandberg and it's about the
teenager Billy Batson who can turn into
the adult superhero after receiving
powers from the wizard and the rock of
eternity just by shouting that Wizards
name Shazam
it's kind of like a wish fulfillment
story they've described as Superman
meets big and it's getting great reviews
currently has 91% of Rotten Tomatoes not
an easy feat and with the exception of
Justice League DC is really having a
great run in terms of critical reception
you know Wonder Woman Aquaman and now
she's Sam they've all been well received
so I'm curious to know from you guys
what do you think about Shazam this
movie that makes it such a hit well I
mean you said it in the wish fulfillment
right it said that it's why you know any
story about a nerd aiming methods kids a
nerd I'm just being mean I'm just gonna
bully in perspective no but like a kid I
seen the the thing that he could become
and in that story of what what if it was
you right actually that's a little bit
of not to get too into spoilers here but
the villain side is a little bit also
like like what if you could become a
hero and then you're not allowed to
become the hero though you know it's
taken away from you I think it's really
speaking to the fact that
you know I'm our fans the fans right now
is in fandom is so obsessed with with
with superheroes that the character is
actually a very representative of the
fans that are going to watch DC movies
they keep the merchandise right it's you
know Marvel fans too and it's like yeah
what if we plucked one of you and said
you're good enough to also join the
Justice League I mean of course that so
maybe we're gonna relate to yes I agree
yeah I want to know who those nine
percent of critics were they did not
give it a good review because they're
just wrong I am by my own accounts one
of the harshest critics of superhero
movies and I absolutely love this film
and I am not just saying that because I
am gainfully employed by also saying
that because I am saying it because it
was a really really really fun watch I
saw it at WonderCon last weekend with a
packed house and man when the audience
gets into it that's you have to see this
in theaters this is not it oh wait for
it to be a no no see it in theaters see
it opening weekend see it second weekend
but see it as soon as you can in
theaters there's so much fun in this
movie I personally like my superhero
movies dark yeah so for me to enjoy this
very honestly light but much lighter
than say like Nolan Batman would be a
kind of fair I really enjoyed it and I
gotta say I think I think the actors
were perfectly cast oh for sure everyone
in this movie is perfect for the role
they are playing on Adam Brody is in the
cast I'm not gonna say exactly what role
he plays but when he when he shows up I
was like oh man that was perfect casting
he does exactly the booth should play
that but on the flip side the kid it's
I'm getting the perfect kid actors his
heart it's very difficult for movies and
they nailed it across the board Darla
just shout out your perfect casting and
her entire journey throughout the movie
is perfect especially where they where
those kids end up by the end of the film
is I didn't realize how emotional
emotionally something I was like crying
I was just like my heart was warmed by
where these kids ended up is
specifically Billy and Freddie Freddie
felt like the heart of this movie for me
I mean Billy's adventure it he's the
superhero so you you connect with that
and you relate to that you get excited
for him but Freddie he's the one that
you would be in that point of view in
this story you're the one who has to
experience it you're watching somebody
else get to have all the fun and yeah
you could get like maybe you get jealous
from that maybe you support him maybe
you encourage him to explore more the
exploration of what Shazam can do is one
of the best parts of any superhero movie
that's come out and like the past 10
years honestly because it was
unapologetic this entire movie is it
well it takes so many deep cuts where
it's like even if I sat down and
explained them to you now I don't know
if that's nothing any justice to how
bonkers it is in bonkers is in the most
positive way I can say because it's just
kudos kudos David F Sandberg remembered
this guy yeah I think the his direction
and his ability to balance the tone of
this story was really impressive I've
been following this guy for a while
because he used to make horror shorts on
YouTube exactly guy he made lights out
and he directed a lot of shorts with his
wife Lata and she's actually I believe
she makes a cameo in this film and he's
such an impressive horror director he
made the film version of lights out he
directed one the ant about movies
there's also a little Annabelle Easter
egg if you were right closely this movie
was scary there's a lot of like
interesting jump scares sure I mean
these villains like are like not only
are they scary to look at like the great
there's really great design in them but
they're like about like the deep human
sins and flaws that we all have deep
down which is so much like deeper than
then you know I also was in that gamma
ray accident and I'm here for revenge
right well what this reminded me of is I
was telling you about this and before
that we taped a it reminded me a lot of
Sam Raimi's first spider-man film and
maybe the second spider-man film where
they also took another horror director
who's better known for his horror work
gave him a superhero origin story and he
kind of leaned into the ooze a meanness
of the story and didn't really make fun
of it and it felt like kind of a fresh
throwback feel watching Shazam because
now everyone's so post post post
everything and ever has a comment
everything and it says Deadpool arrived
it just kind of broke all superhero
movies in a good way
but it was nice to kind of like go back
and believe in a superhero story again
and feel like a kid again I really like
when you go through a story that we've
seen before and you find one part of it
that hasn't really been explored and you
kind of stay there for a second that's
where this movie takes place you brought
up spider-man I think it'd be this movie
is kind of like what if you were
spider-man you know what if you were
Peter Parker's roommate or something you
were on the same field trip you're there
you put your hand in the same spot and
then you move it away just before the
radioactive spider it goes and then you
know the radioactive spider bites Peter
but then you see he becomes spider-man
because of that and then even though
it's like oh no you know he guess that
that one night where he gets really
sweaty and he feels sick and then he's
like ripped after that he's like
swinging around town he's funnier I
think and then you just like I mean and
my hand was right there and like it's
not only like oh man that job should be
mine it's like I could have been more
than human if I had just like left my
hand there and this story just stays
right there with like just all the
different ways that plays out both you
know with with characters good
characters that are kind of like man I
kind of wish it was me and then
characters I take that to the extreme
where it's like it must be me it should
have been me and this is like adapted
from the new 52 Shazam like backup story
for like the Justice League and I think
that's a great who's such a good like
the good way to condense a lot of the
weirdness from Shazam but also kind of
have a new take with it cuz Billy back
in the 40s was just a kid who got to
wish fulfillment it's great new 52
they're like what if we had like a
little bit of an edge to Billy and
personally I was like that's okay it
wasn't my favorite aspect of it about
how he ends up getting his abilities and
in this movie I was like that's a
perfect reason for him to get the
abilities like it though reason why he
be honest is am over anybody else he's
my favorite reason where it's like
honestly I don't have enough time to
think about it
that's that might be the most relatable
part of this movie and there are so many
solid digs at like superhero movies in
general but on but they're done with a
way that's like it's more of a dig at
the villain than it is of the hero and I
have I had a lot of fun with that and
the character designed the CG is
top-notch in this and I love the way
that they built out families and other
superhero movies but the family in this
movie feels just true I love big props
to the kids but also the foster parents
I'm not so sweet because I didn't feel
like oh we're a big family come on you
got to come do this thing with us it was
like no it felt more like you're joining
a team and I like that feeling where it
was just like no I get it
we were you we know we can't understand
you like your specific situation but we
understand your general emotional
well-being right now and we will let you
figure that out but also we'll call you
on it - I love it there's so many
elements in this that just make it feel
like it works in the real world but at
the same time there are people saying
magic words and they're turning into the
action figures yeah what's funny the
movies is very light that way but
something you just said Sam triggered
for me triggered me reminded me that it
actually is asking like a pretty deep
question because of this idea of
selecting who should be the rightful
heir to the Shazam powers this idea of
oh you know it's got to be someone of a
certain purity and perfect and that's
something we build up our heroes right a
hero can only be someone who is pure of
heart or that's like the best intentions
who is without sin and that's kind of
Barry Clark Kent right where he attends
in America yeah they had to be raised in
this perfect way and it's like there's
so few people that could be that and
this movie asks or if we trusted someone
and we gave them the opportunity could
they step up to that and become the hero
that we need them to be which is like
really like optimistic honestly it's
like goodbye a nice story that you know
a lot of times I think people feel like
you know you've made some mistakes or
like maybe you know there's certain life
that isn't there for you and it's like
well no maybe there still could be you
know if you were given the opportunity
mm-hmm and the again the training
montage is amazing and also just seeing
how Billy would honestly behave with
these abilities it's like yeah
because I would do the same thing right
right now I yeah like why would in the
world when I go to work I would do this
life I would choose to be Shazam fun
casting things so dr. sivana played
brilliantly by Mark Strong his father in
the movies played by John Glover the man
and we all remember who we all remember
from Batman and Robin as oh I can't
believe I'm blanking on his character's
name but he's a guy poison ivy he's been
playing the same role for 50,000 years
for DC yeah hey he was in Smallville
honestly he they took him off the show
spoilers for that show
I was super bummed does he have this
contract that I will only play like shut
up to him and for not really aging a lot
of water no he had a great 30 40 years
yeah yeah I know I mark strong really
killed it as soon as they said he was
the villain like oh my god I don't care
I don't care what you even give him to
say hey because he's gonna I'm gonna be
intimidated immediately you know what's
fun about Mark Strong is that for some
reason in my head like you know I'm not
always good good with I don't know
keeping people separate I keep switching
him with from Devil Wears Prada Oh
Stanley Tucci's on my head when I heard
mark Strong was gonna play the villain I
was like Stanley Tucci Stanley Tucci
taught high school English mark Strong
was the gym coach yeah it's a nature
versus nurture experiment yes like Mark
Strong will throw a kickball at you if
you don't if you don't that's tag back
yeah well if you give one kid a name the
name strong and one could name too chief
see how that works
I can't wait to see Shazam play around
with more DC characters the ones we have
now Aquaman I want to see him play
around with Ezra Ezra Miller's flash I
I'm on board away I will see but I'll
say I'm on board with you three we're
talking about the news worries that he
may not still be attached but we don't
know we don't know yeah but but as we
know right now like mainly my favorite
part of Justice League was a fish a
cyborg and I want one
I also since it was like his first like
big movie I'm like give him another shot
yeah bring him back and also in the
comics Shazam and cyborg as like the
younger members kind of have a rapport
and I'm like that sounds cool I would
really like to see that so well there's
a lot of good things to talk about with
Shazam and we have to move on but let us
know down in the comments below what
your favorite part of the movie was and
we'll be doing more and more videos
about it hopefully a post-credits scene
breakdown is up on the channel now and
we'll have a big Easter egg breakdown
coming out next week coz there were a
lot interesting details that I look
forward to rewatching it but now comes a
time for a trivia question alright
moving on to this week's trivia question
so remember the stakes of this or life
or death you're new here but this could
be your last day so probably love you've
settled your affairs thank you uh-huh
I'll hand out our index cards and you
guys get some pens and you guys can play
along at home the winner here it gets to
take one of our lives
all right great in the 1988 movie big
Tom Hanks and his friend sing a little
ditty called down down baby or the ice
cream song finished this line from the
song I'm cool I'm hot blank okay all of
our answers are here in the trivia box
at the end of the episode we will reveal
the answer the loser as always will
suffer some horrible fate yes I'm
feeling pretty confident and what have
you heard this week oh buckle up kids
cuz we got a new avengers endgame spot
that dropped yesterday and it's got a
few news shots including a shot of Erik
Selvig scientists from the horror movie
is played by stellan skarsgård listed as
missing oh no God Stalin no this seems
to suggest that he is among the dusted
Oh No but that would totally negate the
infinity war tie-in book where he and
Darcy Lewis tried to figure out what
caused the snap which is now being
referred to as the decimation it also
blows up a lot of Avengers and game fan
theories so hole
for just a second gank is say it's gonna
get rough a lot of people thought his
notes from Thor the dark world might be
the key to the time travel or alternate
reality hopping that the Avengers will
need to do to defeat Thanos and bring
everybody back so assuming the MCU isn't
contradicting itself where do you think
salvat could be and could his
imaginative approach to theoretical
physics and end up playing a role as
scientists like stark and banner devised
a way to defeat Thanos do you think it's
gonna be involved in some way and where
could he be well here's the deal so that
that board where they saw all the faces
of like missing like everyone know like
Oh it means he's dead it means he's
dusted well I mean Scott Lang shows up
on that board too and they just don't
know where he is he's trapped in the
corner bro I mean it's chaos the world
is in chaos figuring out where everybody
is you know this is like everyone's
phones are dead after a busy concert and
I was just trying to figure out if accan
is what the snap was it's a light power
outage we actually we did a whole video
breaking down that chalkboard and you
know you can find all kinds of fun
Easter eggs that I think the set
designers are just like we're gonna put
in every possible theoretical physics
term like I think there's a Schrodinger
reference in there they have like the
nine the fault the crosswords lots of
stuff implying like alternate and
parallel I don't think he'll be part of
the story just if I'm thinking like how
they're probably gonna lay out and map
out the story for endgame I would be
surprised I'm ruling it out but I would
be surprised if he plays a huge role in
cracking the code I mean honestly he
could have just made his way over to
that bath house where Thor had the
vision about all the Infinity stones
remember that was like I have Thor was
able to figure out the plot of the next
like nine movies I could probably do
that too so maybe he's over there take a
little bath but since I think you guys
are both on the side of missing right
and I don't think he's or or hiding
maybe like maybe really lame scared but
more like I'm the one that could figure
this all out so it's very important that
you know that no one can find me on a
weekend retreat up in a cat
like really like don't I want to get
away for it you know the world saving
retreat yeah I am I for DC not Marvel so
I have no problem spoiling Marvel
properties there you go and I actually
know the answer to this so I'm gonna I'm
gonna spoiler alert he is in Talladega
Alabama go on because he knew stuff was
going down and he's like I probably only
have days to live so I want each day to
feel like an eternity mm-hmm so he just
went to Talladega Alabama where each day
feels like an eternity see with the wall
watching those fast cars go in circles
all day doesn't feel like a minute has
gone by I have to know what tala gate
day God did to you
it's just there's a Piggly Wiggly slow
slow decline into death it does sound
like the perfect retreat I looked into
this whole cosmic quest book that Selvig
is in that is supposedly Canobie is a
lot of tie in books and time italian
comic series are supposed to be canon
but it's it's more of like a youth
literature book it's why a novel it
feels like it's it's like kind of a kid
story all these adult themes but it uh
it feels like it's not it's probably not
dead they kind of they go on an
adventure and it's after the snap and
they they're trying to figure out what
happened to the world and they are able
to figure out what the stones are and I
think still they actually sees they know
some of those stories yeah but uh oh
we're at the Piggly Wiggly well they
have thick pants there
so the to answer the question though I
think that theoretical physics
absolutely could play a role
in how they saved the day I think who
knows maybe even Eric sell bags notes
can be part of it I don't think that
means that Erik Selvig needs to be part
of the movie you see so many of the top
scientists in the universe just like in
their contact list I think they're fine
I think we will get h Road zinger
reference in in game I'm gonna put that
out there right now I think we're gonna
get a reference to the cat or cats both
dead and alive in a box and maybe
someone will say English please and then
what I think we'll get it right this
wasn't does time travel and someone
grabs a piece of paper folders lurkin
walk two hours into the three hour movie
yeah yeah there was some other news that
came out this week Philip you yeah I was
gonna I mean I made you guys all watch
it before we started because I was
obsessed with it the new Joker trailer
dropped started so this is the for the
version starring walking in Phoenix and
directed by Todd Phillips I thought it
was really dang good yeah I was like
genuinely surprised I don't like
anything did a breakdown for us for it
any a lot of people have this conspiracy
theory about why Eric didn't do that
that breakdown and it's all true he's
like they didn't see another video that
came out three hours before that I'm in
they can't you got sick once it happened
alright so what I thought was really
interesting though is that you know we
were all like we were just seeing these
leaked set photos right and we were like
this movie looks kind silly like it was
he has a chase his nose down the street
or whatever like I don't know it just it
just obviously maybe that's why we
shouldn't look at things that they don't
want us to look at but then once they
did is like totally shocked me that it
had this energy of ill Pagliacci Rosie
at the Italian opera it's a story of the
sad clown it's busy of the clown tragedy
a lot of you know the artwork is
inspired by it by that idea and then it
also really reminded me of that episode
of Seinfeld about that clown that kind
of like loses his mind and like
terrorizes the character showing up and
yeah yeah exactly which I want
our fans to create a mash-up of the
trailer and the Seinfeld episode but
what my question is for you guys is you
know this is the first time they're
probably like okay this is our movie now
judge it huh so go ahead judge it what's
it what's this trailer doing for you how
do you feel about this movie it's
honestly was super cool just a just like
a as a DC fan it was cool that there
weren't any other studio logos except
for do you see at the end I was like you
know they're doing like a whole thing
now that makes me excited that's like or
like Marvel Studios doesn't have like a
Disney logo that starts in the beginning
it's just Marvel Studios like this is
just yeah yeah
gave it a couple planned go a little
time but no after this trailer I think I
was just on the fence I don't I you guys
could correct me if I've ever said that
I'm like Oh an origin movie for the
Joker just isn't my cup of tea but
honestly I God said that you know it's I
get people being hesitant because he's
also a mass murderer so the journey of
that character could be all harrowing by
the end but also that's pretty
intriguing and what Todd Phelps wants to
build here I find I do find super
interesting and I think you just kind of
nailed it when you got Joaquin Phoenix
cuz immediately I'm interested like
immediately I'm gonna see the movie just
on the basis of him being in it and his
his physicality and it makes me feel I
learned this from my therapist recently
pulling your stomach like deep in and
holding it like tight is like one of the
most liked like distracting things you
can do like your mind searches like kind
of freaked out you have so many nerve
endings in your stomach we can all try
it you can try a headphone or your Eric
does it all episode long but something
you just said I just was really
interested in me this idea that we have
complained in the past like do we want
to know the story of someone becoming a
mass murderer and do we want to
potentially even sympathize with them
and something that I noticed is that
there's it looks like there's a
potential love interest in this story
and I think that's a great way to take
that story is okay maybe it's not so
much of us you know feeling bad for him
it's someone we can actually relate to
in a different way and like the stakes
are for her that you know to maybe be
his last chance at not becoming that and
you know the inevitable sadness would
that she's gonna be stricken with when
he or you know worse when he turns
anyway yeah I I am unable to give
credit because I saw this as a meme on
the interwebs but I saw this yesterday
and I thought this is perfect and it was
like Joker 1989 I don't know just drop
him in a vat of acid Joker 2019 I don't
know just drop him into society and and
I was like oh yeah no that's absolutely
crass and so yeah I don't know so I saw
a lot of people complaining like oh man
you want me to sympathize with this guy
now and I don't necessarily know that I
think it's interesting that people are
getting that from the trailer I will
reserve judgment till I see the movie
but maybe we're not asking to sympathize
with the Joker maybe they're just saying
like hey this is what made this guy
crazy you don't have to agree with them
but this is the story we're gonna tell
and I'm very curious to see that story
even if it's you know if if there's
breaks in reality for the guy and I
expect that there probably will be but
I'm I'm anxious to see it not because I
want to sympathize with potential mass
murderers but it's always interesting I
mean in our society right now how
obsessed are we as a culture with like
serial killers oh yeah how many I'm not
less yeah yeah it's like no no here's
another documentary about a guy who
killed fifteen B is it based on all that
like one person at this table as a
serial killer 109e
he's hiding underneath he's gonna get so
I think that this movie is very much of
the moment at least in that trailer what
we saw again I reserve judgment till
they see the full movie but I'm very
excited about it and let's just let's
just you know hypothesize this maybe
this isn't a universe where the Joker is
a mass murderer maybe this is a universe
where it's just a guy pushed to his own
limits and then maybe it involves
killing maybe it doesn't maybe any
killing he does is justifiable and then
that's it we're gonna get a different
kind of Joker than the one we had before
because you could certainly say Heath
Ledger's Joker was not Cesar Romero's
Joker you know very differ
jokerz so I mean we are 11 years away
from Heath Ledger's Joker now so it's
entirely possible that this is just a
totally different take on the character
and I'm very curious to see what it is
yeah already it feels like it's
different than the Joker that we know
because the Joker that we know doesn't
have a clear past you know I believe
that the version of Heath the version
that Heath Ledger's went with Heath
Ledger had a mysterious nebulous
backstory and he kept changing his story
and that to me is what the true Joker is
the fact that we're seeing
Arthur Fleck that's not it's already an
alternate universe Joker and I think a
lot of people will see a movie and be
like well there's a hero to it that hero
must be presented in a good light that
must be someone we have to root for and
identify with but I'll remind you
there's plenty of like gangsters stories
there's plenty of TV series in which
we're supposed to see the moral decline
there's plenty of Shakespeare plays in
which we're supposed to charge and hate
the main care yeah Breaking Bad is you
know a story where you over the course
of this series realized damn I'm rooting
for the bad guy right and then I think
Sopranos is another example before
Breaking Bad that you know it had the
problem in its final season where people
felt like oh at least we started like
Tony but in the final season David Chase
had to specifically do some monstrous
things with Tony and make him such a
hateable character so that by the end
you wanted to see him die like he had to
die for you to go to bed that night and
then you know he cut the plaque and then
we just have to draw our own conclusions
but I think that's there's a whole side
of storytelling where you can have a
character you follow the whole time and
it is a judgment and it seems like this
Joker story is borrowing from things
like taxi driver or things like the king
of comedy which have been like
referenced by the filmmakers as
influences and in both of those stories
you're not supposed to root for the main
character maybe some deep dark side of
you does but at the end of the day
you're not supposed to emulate their
behavior last thing I'd mention is that
with this trailer there you're seeing
that it's been expressed that he is a
mentally ill man who eventually spirals
into this whatever whatever version that
is well I think what most people connect
you to the Joker is that he is a
murderer so that like this mentally ill
person is pushed to becoming a murderer
and something that is like worshipped
because he basically is the start of a
movement and there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of heat around that right
now
especially with our criticism
specifically like when split or glass
came out you're seeing your main
antagonist be someone who is mentally
ill and that is the biggest part of his
personality based on one you see the
trailer and I think with splitting glass
you guys can not like those movies for
whatever reason I think that the writers
did enough work in that to show that
like we're not talking about mental
illness this is a special case where
it's supernatural and then what what is
happening to him it is not a mental
illness and if it is it's a we're just
trying to show that it's okay to go to
therapy and get help I hope that this
movie in a sense I don't have the same
criticisms for this trailer I just hope
that when looking at mental illness in
this movie that there we are shown that
there are tools for you to go get help
and to address those problems and in his
case it's a special situation and he is
not a monster for being having mental
illness but he makes decisions that turn
him into a mosque right I hope that it's
not that he starts with mental illness
and then that just like devolves from
there I think could be really
interesting if he starts kind of normal
right relatable where we are and we see
is it possible to take it your average
man and take him just give him the exact
you know formula this happened something
this and this and it just lines up where
it could have been any of us could you
really push someone so far that they
become the disgusting person that sticks
two fingers in a kid's mouth you thought
about the Joker trailer is this making
you come around on what you worried
about or are you more excited than you
were before but I wanted to run another
thing by you guys that I saw this week
we got an update on the new Terminator
movie it's called terminator dark fate
it's starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
former California Governor Joyce and
what's a movie star yeah why would the
cast a minute at Lando hit Linda
Hamilton is back playing Sarah Connor
and Hamilton the heart of the story some
might say James Cameron is also heavily
involved and remembers so this is the
thing with this movie it's not going to
be a sequel to all the franchise it's
only gonna be a sequel to Terminator and
t2 Judgment Day
so it's resetting the franchise the
events of Terminator 3 Terminator
Salvation and terminator genisys and
Terminator kids and Sarah keep your hat
- sorry
yeah now this week we got some photos of
Arnold and Hamilton Mackenzie Davis and
the rest of the cast all of whom look
very angry ready to kick our asses away
break eye contact we got an official
logo for it of the title and CinemaCon
guests were actually treated to some
footage there was a scene that shows a
nonhuman character played by Mackenzie
Davis beating up some cops in Mexico
City and there's another scene where
Sarah Connor shows up with a bazooka and
they showed a real with clips of lots of
action featuring car explosion
Schwarzenegger is just flexing I guess
and Sarah Connor dropping the iconic
line I'll be back and she blows up a
bridge I don't know why she would say
that to the bridge but I will fix this
the insurance guy yeah the director is
Tim Miller this the guy director
Deadpool and he mentioned that the new
Terminator will meet in this movie can
split into two and become twice as
deadly
he can split it he can split in two and
become twice as though it's maybe like
the t1000 you know how he could oh I
hope it's in my head I was thinking of
the t800 machine but like just like
one-legged hopping have you into doors
or two smaller Terminator Chucky
terminators pretty terrifying they keep
dividing that you have billions of
little tiny terminators well I wouldn't
have you guys this idea of a whole
franchise reset you know where you skip
certain sequels for whatever reason it's
become kind of a trend lately and a
couple different franchises we start
with the newest Halloween movie which
assume that all the other Halloween
movies after the first one didn't happen
and then it's happening with this new
Jason Reitman Ghostbusters he's doing
Ghostbusters 3 it's pertaining the 2016
Ghostbusters didn't happen and now with
the Terminator movies that's happening
it's is it allowing for more
possibilities to expand the universe do
you think do you think this is like
cheating do you think they should have
to reference I mean like right Star Wars
just pretended the prequels didn't
happen but they didn't officially like
say they didn't happen I mean they
didn't reference them that's kind of
what I mean is that they were like look
whatever happened there just does not
bring it up they don't like like didn't
have to go back and say how do we how
the hell do we make all the prequel
stuff work with the new stuff they kind
of like let's just never talk about it
again except for Darth Maul coming up in
solo
one character please leave that in
Brooklyn yeah it seems like in the
standalone ones but maybe in the new
sorry something like that was a way to
do it and then there's this other way
we're like no let's be outright like
let's insult them by saying like no you
are not part of my world yeah I mean I
think so long as it's like the original
creator of it in this case James Cameron
you know it's it's his property that he
did the first two I think really only
he's in the driver's seat to make that
for every every one of the movies that
he's on board with it is it is tiring
now I I don't mind it if it results in a
cleaner universe for better continued
storytelling and especially in the
superhero world it's easy to just go
alright those were just two Elseworlds
movies then that's fine I can just have
you know Bruce Wayne on Mars that's fine
whatever they want to do so in terms of
ghostbusters that was kind of an
Elseworlds because that was supposedly
in a different universe right then that
one pretended that the other two didn't
have right yes so that one I don't see
really a conflict there but certainly
with terminator I mean you know they
tried retconning it with terminator
genisys and so it didn't quite pan out
like they hoped and I'm ok with it I
mean they Sarah Connor Chronicles
retconned Terminator 3 it's a story
about wreck coming right yeah it was a
story about a wait only it was only
terminators one and two that that was
building off of they ignored three
salvations sort of incorporated three so
this has been both a messy world on
screen and a messy very messy world off
screen with the rights to the Terminator
franchise has been a hot topic of
contention for many years so I'm very
glad that that seems to be settled now I
am a huge terminator universe fan so I'm
very excited about this and also I
didn't hate any of the other Terminator
movies Terminator 3 is much better than
that scenario earlier and
I mean we probably just did should talk
about it now this idea that like I don't
hate any of the Terminator movies either
but I know I kind of should sometimes
like it's weirdly I don't know if it's
the that amazing score but like as soon
as that starts playing I just get like
hype yeah yeah and then I'm just down
with it yeah and then later like maybe a
year later some damn I yeah and make any
sense
yeah but personally I think the biggest
knock to the Terminator movies is every
single piece of advertisement
salvation the biggest twist that could
have happened in that movie was Sam
Worthington is in the trailer if you had
hidden that that would have been a great
reveal and I would have been a more on
board they ruined genesis in the trailer
the last trailer that comes out you're
like it was in the theater I was
watching it's like wait oh my god I
shouldn't I shouldn't be watching that's
like this is the end of the movie I am
seeing how this movie plays out from
start to finish there's one thing like
some more time-travel elements I didn't
know we're gonna happen but everything
else is the same
it is spoiled and I and I hate that I
like three because I watched as a kid
and there's some like sixteen I was
allowed to drive here my job I was
younger and so and I enjoyed it for what
it was I can see the criticism in
Salvation I like to see a Christian Bale
I was I think that's what it is about
the The Terminator movies they have this
scored I think the first two were so
good it's almost to me like the aliens
franchise you know the James Cameron
what I like aliens i watch you know
alien covenant I enjoyed I like
Prometheus I don't care what rage I'll
get like I think I come I compare the
two franchise for the first two are just
so great I'll see ya
you know there's something to be said
about the it's is we're acting like it's
a mystery but it's the character right
the character of the Terminator the
character was aliens
yeah the character of these aliens it's
it's even in Halloween right it sees
these ideas of they're all stories about
like the boogeyman but basically and I
mean for millennia we keep telling
stories about the same characters with
slight variations I think that's maybe
why we give it so much wiggle room
versus like another story where it's a
very specific character that can only be
told for instance that's why we noticed
how many times we reboot spider-man it's
like that's such a that's not the
bogeyman story right that's like a very
specific
sorry Gary yeah and he can boogie yeah
so I think maybe they'll have room
forever that said I'll still say
bringing back a Linda Hamilton which
amazing I'm so excited about kind of
makes it feel like this is their last
chance to start over
could I have one question for you guys
how do you think they're gonna explain
why Sports Nagar is so old before in
Genesis it was like time travel they get
sold
yeah ages living tissue over a
cybernetic oh the living tissue
continues to age yeah
but weirdly like a human W seems to
continue to rot okay well Sam there's
some other news a great now I'm
Terminator News so buckle up kids and we
heard the David Harbor from stranger
things has been cast in the Black Widow
movie very Rachel wait wasn't she
announced it's up in the it's up in the
air there's Prague confirmed even Harbor
as far as we know is confirmed so that's
very exciting I love him but we also
have a confirmation for Jai Courtney
reprising his role as Captain Boomerang
in the James on the Suicide Squad movie
I really like him that he's maybe one of
the best guys understand yes here's a
GoPro on boomerang the flies around and
rumor has it that James Gunn is
currently casting an alien femme fatale
character so that'll be fun as well
Oh some aliens in there why not go for
it just came out today that Kumail
Nanjiani is in talks to star in the MCU
Eternals movie with Angelina Jolie which
is pretty cool as well finally those two
get together
also Avengers endgame tickets went on
sale and promptly crashed all ticket
sites this week they said a ton of
presale records and it was real crazy I
waited for three hours but I got the
screening I wanted and I wasn't too
close to the screen boy yeah I got
tickets but I can't even sit with the
people I wanted to sit with it's yeah
we're different with the people yeah
like a random church field trip there
for 10:30 at night yes like yeah mine is
for the Incredible Hulk
yeah middle of that marathon but
actually if you guys had trouble getting
tickets do not worry we actually got you
guys and this is really exciting for us
this is part of our celebration for
having 2 million subscribers we are
actually going to be hosting a special
screening of Avengers end game on the
Friday it comes out Friday April 26 that
opening weekend at the world-famous El
Capitan Theatre in Hollywood it's
Disney's official movie theater Wow it's
also gonna be totally tricked-out for
endgame plus we're not just gonna have
you guys there and you get to watch the
movie you also get to attend a live
taping of this show that we're gonna be
doing from the El Capitan and then
what's crazy we're gonna mingle with you
guys is way more impressive than either
you're just gonna like periscope one of
the screenings no we're gonna do a
meet-and-greet with you guys there and
then we're also we're gonna have
kick-ass gas work you know celebrities
if famous babies we're going to feed you
if you come there it's gonna be a really
great time so all that said tickets are
$75 but just being real honest here
we're not making any money on this thing
that's the you're getting the movie
ticket you're getting the live like
taping in this like special lounge that
like is a special Disney place you also
nerd out with us in person we feed you
you will get time to do whatever you
want to Eric
it all goes directly to good causes like
that there are however only 50 tickets
Oh God so definitely jump on that as
soon as they're available we're gonna
announce it across our socials of
exactly how to get those tickets and
then you know you can fly here but this
is in LA so you know just keep that in
mind if you're like I got my ticket I
live in a last a youth hostel right
walking distance from the El Capitan yes
I'll meet you there
no I run the hospital uggs it any chance
to keep absolutely
we got beds and pillows and you need one
1/2 bathroom so if this doesn't sound
glamorous enough remember we're gonna
feed you there - yes yeah well yeah
definitely jump on that now it's time to
move on to our new rock stars debrief
lightning round
you guys screen into some questions is
it raining men are you gonna answer them
as quickly without hesitation as
possible are we ready no all right
starting with for Sam bachelor at Davi
backward dad know by now who is your
second favorite the holding world knows
the flash is here first who's your
second favorite DC character plastic
quick okay Schwartz please get that role
I mean he's gonna get her and he's gonna
sell produce it and then he's gonna do
plastic man please for Phillip at sensei
undersquare I am if you could shout out
any word to become a superhero what
would that word be oh wow
for Sam you know is the most overrated
and which is the most underrated
overrated none of them I don't know the
most overrated the most underrated of
the DC Universe I am the flash frankly
really yeah I think flash does not get
the respect flash deserves flash can
travel through time okay that's pretty
impressive in universes yeah that's a
big deal he doesn't wield it very well
though the specifics well it's
undervalued because he has not getting
the respect he deserves and he's not
chosen not to master it yet yeah yeah
first you get the respect then you get
the mastery not you that's not usually
how it works yes sensei for me at
kanashii
add two pseudo wants to know what did
you think DC stands for before
knew what it really means okay so when I
was a kid wasn't there like a TV
production company called deke they also
make comics yeah I would have assumed it
was Dick Clark down for Sam at Andy
eighteen wants to know what less known
DC superheroes should be brought to life
in the DC Universe I mean I wouldn't and
he's not lesser number a Lobo on screen
would be really cool with the chain I'm
also a bit too though I mean I'm a flash
family as well do the whole flash family
I mean they got bored with that impulse
would be fun if we're going like way
down the line like crazy way down do new
Superman is Chinese Superman he's great
the way he gets his powers and his just
the the the Justice League of China is
so cool that come I got ended last year
and I definitely definitely cried just a
tiny bit in my room okay for for Sam
what other Batman villain if any would
you like to see in Joker oh man um what
Batman villain do I want to see in Joker
uh I think I think we're due for a
poison ivy update oh I think that would
be a a plum role for any number of great
Hollywood actresses and not to say that
Huma Thurman didn't do a great job with
it but that's so far the only poison ivy
live-action we've seen and I would love
to see another poison ivy poison ivy
that doesn't start as a dancing gorilla
they want one from and this is CRLs -
and - what's so favorite villain one
from DC and one from Marvel Marvel is
gonna be magneto I love the fact that
like magneto is a result of someone
saying it oh this character have the
powers of magnetism and they were like
wait holy crap that is HUGE if you think
about it and then it was that's awesome
and also everything about him is great
DC it's mr. freeze that's I just like
something about the animated series
episode was awesome
there's that and also I just like relate
to is like no I was gonna say like how
like robotic he is like but like he's
still a human I don't know
he's cool yeah he's such a tragic yeah I
love it yeah for me at pretty at all
wants to know our Avengers stuck in a
time loop hell yeah they are we got a
video coming out on Monday about that
moving on us say olivine um at mister
fiesta 27 with snow best sidekick and
why Oh Robin yep it's an easy answer but
what's one oh that's a fair question I
want to say Jason Todd but no Dick
Grayson yeah yeah I love that story
the in Batman 1000 there was a bunch of
little shorts and there's one in there
oh god what's it called the precedent
and it's where Alfred has to argue the
case for Dick Grayson to Bruce and I
loved that twist on it and where it's
like no if we let him go it could be bad
man you can connect with this kid better
than anyone's gonna connect with him you
know what he's going through and that's
why I think Dick Grayson and Bruce Wayne
work so well together is because of
their shared backstories and yeah Boy
Wonder Man if you imagine Bruce Wayne
started an orphanage it's creating an
army okay so things like a government
would be called really quick okay for me
Evan and a bunch of numbers wants to
know if you could pick any Justice
League remember to jump out of the pages
of your comic looking for some Eric love
who would it be and why dianna they
demanding Eric yeah looking for some
Eric love well I mean I'll love any of
them you know I already love all of them
in that way but
yeah I think both answers in either case
would be let's just leave it you feel
very uncommon in the comments for
bachelor at Katherine boats was so if
you could be Superman for 24 hours
what's the first thing you would do fly
to the moon okay yeah the moon and do
what there I and Superman all slash
Superman he and Krypto sit on the moon
and they look at earth and it that comic
will maybe cry and it's one of my
favorite it's Frank Wiley's art and it's
absolutely beautiful also a little moon
I gotta put my footprint down right next
buzzes and Neil's you don't want to get
your ass to Mars I don't know if I have
its 24 hours I don't know how quick I
can go just depends on what kind of
Superman I am you know Superman do you
want to be the best one
and finally for Phillip at center blow
out bully gives you when you got a bad
haircut what happened to someone who we
do mini cheetos yeah and like couldn't
make it through 12 or to the bathroom
let us know all the different
definitions of cheddar blowout on urban
dictionary okay what would the name of
Thor's and Captain Marvel's hypothetical
son ooh a Hugh Jackman maybe man that
would be a killer son yeah dam burst
yeah especially the DC version of
Captain Marvel Yeah right yeah great
progressive question and now comes a
time for our 15-second shout outs where
each of the fifteen seconds to shout out
plug or ramble about anything we want
Sam no thank you
a really quick shout-out to might be
awesome it's a new YouTube channel that
my friend DJ launched this week and oh
my god I haven't slept and I have tummy
aches that I might need to go to a
doctor about cuz if it's so stressed but
now it launched and it's got a really
cool response is deep dives not like
them don't worry you get your new rock
stars deep dives here they're those we
do we answer like kind of like weird
questions and we use 8-bit animations to
kind of explain like the bigger concepts
first one was what happens after the
snap I didn't know they were work on
that one when we
but it's different we end up in
different places so different answers
you could have it that question only one
correct answer get out and maybe
subscribe maybe like it and share it
that's how other people see it look
great let's see I don't really have a
particular shoutout this week I will
just say go watch us again because
there's so much to that movie if you
haven't seen it already go check it out
it's it's a different movie than get out
is it's not fair to compare them but man
there's so many questions that I have
coming at that movie and every time I
rewatched it I find something new about
and I would love to do like a whole
breakdown of it because there's just
someone so many details and interesting
things that Jordan Peele snuck into that
cool I'm gonna do two quick shout let's
always do two one I'm gonna say check
out the Cobra Kai trailer for season two
that just came out season 1 is really
cool but I got to do some some cool work
with with the team from Cobra Kai or
something yeah I trained them all so I'm
more announcements about that but it's
really exciting the other thing I was
just say it's a time of year to start
wishing happy birthday Derek yeah it's
you know he doesn't like any people no
into exact details about him but they
know everything but if you want to start
being nice to them on social media it'd
be a good time to start well as you can
see by my vast wealth of DC knowledge if
you want to be as knowledgeable as I am
about DC which is the most knowledgeable
you need to get yourself a subscription
to DC Universe comm where you can watch
me and my cohorts five days a week on DC
daily and you can check out awesome
shows like season one of titans season
one of Doom Patrol
we got Swamp Thing coming up in May what
else we got Young Justice Outsiders
thank you very much they are adding
20,000 comic books to the library and
then it's quite a few so DC Universe
comm you can get a free week trial and
you're gonna love it and then you're
gonna get yourself an annual
subscription and you'll thank me later
he's watching Patrol so I can talk to
someone about it thank you we are now
returning to the trivia question that we
asked yeah so that question was in the
1988 movie big Tom Hanks and his friends
sing a little ditty called down down
baby or the ice cream song finished this
line for
the song so we'll read I'll read the
lines from the song and each of us will
go down and just fill in the blank as I
say it are you ready
we'll start with Sam who has my answer
all right I'm cool
I'm hot I'm funky funky cheesy mold
that's what you rap that sounds right oh
I forgot that I tried to rhyme with the
word cold which was not in speed bump in
there but mine might not line up so Sam
eric is gonna say Sam's answer I'm cool
I'm hot I'm a picture of if it had the
chance to turn into Shazam it has an
eight-pack you know I think that is
actually how though Rapids isn't it it's
a picture of all right is definitely
wrong that you're about to read but it
is definitely in the song all right well
let's hear it if it's this part I'm cool
I'm hot I stole my mama's credit that is
part of the song there's part of
violence all right this is a really
funny song all right and then finally
Eric's answer that Sam's gonna read I'm
cool I'm hot punch me in the stomach one
more time what is this song this song is
so weird I'm feeling
we can say yeah what's the correct all
right so if I the correct answer is I'm
cool I'm hot
suck you in the stomach three more times
oh so close Eric yeah oh three nothing
for three years that's how I got the
stuff yeah I may never have even known
those were the lyrics yeah yeah well
everyone knows how it begins no one
knows really how it is yeah I knew
nothing
well judges who between me and Sam
probably well so so I think they
obviously you the best answer or the
closest answer is certainly these sock
you in the stomach one more time close
enough to three more times
it's who's the furthest I stole my
mama's credit
I'm Services yeah funky funky cheesy
mold he's got eight eyes well and
remember some of these some of these
answers just if you'll notice some of
these answers aren't words
wait no no there's a word no some of
these answers are a comic book panel
arguing people don't know this that
since Shazam has a lot of pulls from big
big actually has some polls from the
original Shazam comic there is an
argument you can make to that and didn't
them and there aren't their kids and
what kids wouldn't be fans of spider-man
and so what if you could mix spider-man
Shazam and say Shazam and turn to
spider-man I'm losing it he tried to
rhyme it with cold and that's not even
like in the song but it is something
songs do they don't have pictures moldy
cheese is like getting socked in the
stomach all right so decided that's
gonna be Sam Sam this is the last gift
of shame in this box right now so
whatever it says you got to do it buddy
hey I mean you guys at least proud of me
for my drawing skills I think it's
pretty cool
proud of you son thank you so I got my
gift of shame is it's the claw think Jim
Carrey and liar liar it attacks that's a
great okay do that on the gift of shame
it'll be turned into a gif if you are
listening to this on podcast form check
us out on social media at new rock stars
and you can see what the heck could talk
yeah
and since we're emptying that gif of
shame box for the moment at least and
we'll bring it back in other ways give
us some ideas for other punishments that
will work for the audio podcast version
yes we know gifts aren't the most fun on
podcast but it's some embarrassing or
goofy or humiliating thing that the
listen audio session in audio form yes
so put divine hold on in brainstorm
while you're driving so as Sam does this
I'll be doing our goodbyes it's the same
you want to take okay great so as Sam
does that I will sign us off thank you
for watching or listening to this week's
episode of new rockstars debrief I want
to thank our host Sam bachelor at Sam
basher Phillip Molina at fimo me air
glass idea box plus special guest Sam
Levine at Sam Levine and reminded that
this episode is available in both audio
and video form the video is at
youtube.com slash new rock stars and you
can get the audio anywhere you listen to
your podcast oh boy and if you happen to
use the Himalaya app we'd really
actually appreciate if you did that and
went and left a comment for us on the
podcast and supports the show directly
so comment and tweet at us at new rock
stars like this video or podcast shared
around and subscribe to new rock stars
with deep dives and all the stuff you
love bye bye everyone you like
[Music]